If you want a
life of purpose,
begin by inverting
the notion
that everything happens
for a reason.
All your efforts,
personal,
professional,
carnal...
You must be willing to
make the hard choices,
do the unpleasant things,
risk your most
valuable assets.
Because nothing
worthwhile
is ever achieved
without sacrifice.
Now that you’re on
the brink of greatness
are there
still limitations
to what you’d be
willing to sacrifice?
In this case, a night
alone with your husband.
Would that be an
acceptable condition
of a firm offer to
finance your company?
What do you really know
about Anne Montgomery?
Things could get
dangerous very quickly.
Things have always
been dangerous.
Sean!
What is it that you
imagine I did to him?
I made a mistake.
But I do not deserve
to lose everything.
Regret is all I’ve felt
since the moment we met.
How many more people
need to be hurt
before you get
what you want?
You’re more committed
than you realize.
The worst kind of victim
is the one that chooses
to create another.
I am no one’s victim.
Are you
absolutely certain
this is the choice
you want to make?
I’m not what
you think I am.
Maybe not.
But I’m beginning to
see potential.
True success
comes at any cost.